hi
welcome to our session on driving
business transformation in retail
using ai i'm carrie tharp and i lead up
retail for google cloud
i'm excited to be here today to chat a
little bit about
the state of ai in retail and how google
cloud is helping
implement ai in businesses like yours
we'll also share a little bit about our
solutions and then share some best
practices
when you think about what's going on in
retail today
the landscape is certainly changing the
pace of change
is accelerating and covid19 has
certainly
thrown a wrench in many plans what's
more important than ever
is the use of data in your business to
help
unlock value whether that's changing
customer experiences
or improving operational performance
when you think about ai and ml in your
business it's a crucial component to the
future of retail strategies
and choices that you may be making today
on your platforms and capabilities
can be a big part of your performance
tomorrow
we're very passionate about driving the
adoption of ai
and ml in retail research shows that
there's certainly value
to using ai and ml in your business
it can help you make more data-driven
decisions
five times faster decision making and
three times faster
to execution however
ai is really still seen in its hype
cycle for retail
we did some recent research in the
specialty and department store
space and found that 60 of retailers
had 20 or more pilots in progress
but when you double clicked on that only
45 percent of those pilots
had been transitioned to full
implementation in production
and then looking at those that had been
implemented
retailers only thought 40 of them
represented
the high value use cases so it's great
to have a mix of potentially low-hanging
fruit
opportunities but there's also still a
big opportunity to go
after where the biggest value in retail
is
so what's holding people back in our
discussions we find that
data availability continues to be an
issue
this really covers a whole host of
problems everything from data being
siloed
and not being able to get at all the
different combinations of customer
transaction product and supply chain
data
to having issues with data tagging and
data modeling
second is technical talent do you have
enough resources on your team
from a technology standpoint or the data
and analytics team to really go
after a lot of these more complicated
use cases
that take more preparation of the data
and a deeper understanding of the
business
last is financial constraints so we all
have kind of scarce resources when we
think about the capital and expense
we're able to deploy in our businesses
and so do you have the right amount of
resources to go after the opportunities
that you see ahead of you
as a team with all the challenges of
implementing ai in retail
it's more important than ever to focus
and prioritize
we've done research to understand where
the value is locked up
in retail and have found that the top 10
to 15 use cases
is actually where most of the value lies
out of hundreds of use cases you could
potentially be thinking about working on
whether it's in food drug and mass or
specialty and department store
you'll see on this list that there's a
couple of key themes
around inventory customer experience and
store operations
google can join you in these
conversations of prioritization to help
you understand
what might be the best opportunities for
you to go after
short term and in the longer term
how google can help from an ai
perspective is in three key buckets
first we're building industry-specific
solutions
that are pre-built and ready-made to
help accelerate your digital
transformation an example would be
vision product search you can plug in
this api
and allow your customers to take
pictures of product and automatically
find it within your catalog
second is using the building blocks that
we've already established
one of the examples here is dialog flow
rather than trying to take on natural
language
understanding to create customer care
chat bots
or voice interaction with your customers
you can use dialog flow as a jump start
to creating those experiences
and third is then just using our
platform to custom build yourself
there's a variety of use cases that you
may feel are very specific to your
business
or don't leverage components that
already exist
when we think about these pre-built
solutions we're focused in three key
areas
first is helping drive digital and
omni-channel growth
so this is think of everything that's a
part of driving digital experience
and your e-commerce business second is
helping you become a data-centric
customer-driven
retailer this is all of the data
platforms and ai and ml that's needed to
help you drive new personalization
customized experiences
and understand your product and
inventory data better
third is operational performance
improvement so this is helping you
unlock operational value inside the p l
whether it's store operations or
reducing your cost
in your infrastructure first let's talk
a little bit more
about driving digital and omni channel
revenue growth
one of the key priorities here is
helping evolve
product discovery when you think about
ecommerce today
it's based on very rigid structures from
site nav
to using a search text box and customer
shopping journey looks
very different than that so we've been
focused on providing solutions that help
you evolve that customer interaction
all retailers are dealing with several
key trends
so first is the changing dynamics in
shopping visits
so covid19 has changed how much
retailers
have customers visiting their stores how
big their basket size is when they visit
and so it's become more important than
ever to provide new digital discovery
experiences
second this environment has certainly
made customer experience
a big priority making sure that your
customer has all their expectations met
whether or not they can interact with an
associate has become critical
and then personalization this has been a
theme
in retail for years but it's now very
important to make sure you're putting
the right
product in front of a customer wherever
their journey may be taking place
our offerings are focused on reducing
friction for shoppers
first is vision product search this is
the capability that i mentioned that
allows you
to use visual images to search your
catalog so think of a grocery store
customer instead of building their list
by writing it down
or searching for it on your app they
could simply take pictures
and pre-load their shopping list next is
recommendations ai
this is focused on providing the best
personalized recommendations for your
shoppers
with a broad understanding of their
journey
and last is search for retail this is
bringing the power of google search
directly to your e-commerce websites
when we think about recommendations
google cloud brings best-in-class
recommendations
based on our experience in building
recommendations as a foundation for
several of our products
that are serving billions of users
worldwide
recommendations ai works in three key
steps
first you seamlessly integrate your
catalog and user events data
with recommendations ai through many of
the tools you're already using
like merchant center google tag manager
google analytics 360
google cloud storage and bigquery as
well as other data sources
in most cases without having to write
any code
once your data is in with a few clicks
you can choose your model type
define your objective and begin training
your model
in three to seven days the initial model
training and tuning will conclude
and you'll see a visual indicator in the
dashboard that the model is ready to
query
you can then begin serving
recommendations to your customers
you can now also visually preview the
recommendations being generated by the
model before you serve them in
production
to make sure that your setup has been
satisfactory
the recommendations are then constantly
improving and optimizing
with daily ai model refreshes
sephora is a customer that's using our
recommendations ai
beauty is certainly a space that
recommendations can be very important to
that purchase journey
and they've seen an increase in both
their click-through rates
as well as their conversion next let's
talk a little bit about
being a customer-centric data-driven
retailer
how can you use data to effectively
predict customer needs
and what your demand might look like
demand forecasting is an example of an
area
that is critical to retail all of
retailers belabor their forecast
trying to make sure that they don't miss
out on revenue opportunities
but also make sure that they don't have
excess products sitting around
this is a product that we have that's in
our early access program
we took on this space because demand
forecasting is still a challenge for
many retailers today
retailers often have trouble integrating
new signals and insights
into their forecast they're often based
on static views of what happened last
year
and maybe some more advanced statistical
modeling
but most retailers see that there's more
opportunity in their forecasts versus
where they're sitting today
there's also challenges understanding
new products and new categories
not having enough information to really
understand what the demand for that
product could be
maybe making those decisions based on
intuition gut
or similar product performance and then
last
many forecasting models don't really
understand local
demand impact of things like weather
consumer behavior and even now
shelter-in-place orders
our google demand forecasting leverages
our best-in-class ai and ml and data
sets from across google
it's designed to integrate with your
current systems and does not require a
rip and replace of platforms that your
merchants and planners may be using
today
explainable ai then helps you better
post
forecast review where you're getting
performance
and what's really a signal inside your
forecast
as of today we've developed ml
algorithms for demand forecasting that
are driving more
accurate forecasts for customers the
solution allows retailers to model
future demand for both long horizon
order planning
as well as short horizon use cases to
feed into allocation replenishment and
planning systems
we are now building out the end-to-end
solution and partnering with a handful
of retailers in the early access program
to take the solution from development to
launch
in addition to this productized solution
we are also working with retailers who
are investing
in their own efforts in this space using
our ai and ml platform offerings
and finally we also work with an
ecosystem of partners
in this space system integrators like
accenture and deloitte
and isvs like o9 who can help you get
results
quickly and realize value from your data
with integrated
and out-of-the-box solutions one example
of a retailer that we're working with in
this space is carrefour
one of the largest grocery retailers in
france
we've partnered with them across a
variety of facets of their business
but one very exciting area is they've
stood up an artificial intelligence lab
in paris
this is a place that their carrefour
engineers partner closely with our
google ai
expert to work on solutions like
optimizing their product assortment
it's very important as you guys know to
have a deep understanding of what's most
relevant
at an individual store location and so
using our recommendations
and ai capabilities to understand that
assortment tailored to the local store
level
has been a great value to carrefour
next let's talk a little bit about
driving operational
excellence providing the best in class
customer care
and support through your call centers
and chats has always been important
but has become ever more important in
the times of covet 19
as call centers have been overwhelmed
with all sorts of questions from
do you have certain inventory in stock
and what are your special shopping hours
like all organizations retailers are
facing a revolution
in customer care 33 of retail customers
will consider switching
to a different retailer if they've had a
bad experience
and estimates show that over the next
several years
ai will be a large component of
providing
service to customers in call centers so
it's important to be thinking about how
you can leverage artificial intelligence
and make impact in your business
google cloud's contact center ai
solution is built for this new world
based around a conversational core that
understands human interaction
and incorporates the context at its core
this virtual agent ai
handles incoming calls or messages and
engages in natural human-like dialogue
to handle common use cases and flows
including having to go off script when
the call can't be handled automatically
it's passed to human agent and the agent
assist ai
steps into support with the relevant
content from the knowledge base
in context about the user and their
situation
the insights ai then surfaces trends and
analysis
to help the entire system improve
for retailers the fact that it's
centralized means you can apply
consistent intelligence across
every application in the customer
journey
the biggest cost savings can often be
found from deflecting voice calls
into your contact center but there's
been challenges in the past because
conversations can meander and ivr trees
may not be able to adapt the inability
to flex to human conversation style
has also historically limited the
ability to assist agents in real time
contextcenter ai has the ability to go
off script so you can work
outside the predefined flow answering
complex questions
full of unexpected stops and starts word
choices or implied meanings
contact center ai also has the ability
to handle
multiple use cases for your customers
like taking a payment
updating information like a phone number
giving them
information about store hours which then
allows you to fully automate routine
tasks and further deflect calls
you can start with an easy use case and
grow your adoption
depending on your organization's needs
during covid19 for example
many retailers were faced with a deluge
of customer inquiries specific to store
timing
and special hours our team offered up a
rapid response virtual agent that could
be set up in
days and take the volume of calls off
your busy agents
and most importantly make sure that
customers felt supported through this
period of heightened anxiety markson
spencer is one of the customers we've
worked with in the context center
ai space they work with our partner
develop
to leverage dialog flow to help manage
their contact center interactions
markson spencer is one of the best
beloved retail brands in the uk
with over 30 million loyal customers and
they had switchboards
in 13 different store locations across
their store footprint
and they were taking 9 million calls a
year you can imagine that's a lot to
understand the different things that
customers may
be calling about specific to that store
but also broader questions that can be
answered more effectively
using dialogflow they were able to
reduce that call volume to the stores by
50 percent
and route more than seven million calls
into the centralized call center
now that we've talked more about our
solutions and some of the challenges
that retailers have
using ai and ml in their business i'd
like to share a little bit about some of
the best practices we see
across all the customers we're working
with first
is understanding your data first
strategy
making sure you're thinking about your
data in a holistic
platform-based approach that really
expands to meet all the needs you have
going forward
unlocking those data silos and bringing
together the product
transaction customer and supply chain
data
second is ai is truly a team sport
getting the value out of ai can often
sit at the intersection
between several different stakeholders
in retail whether it's the merchants
the planners or the marketers they may
have a very different view
of where value sits and how your brand
should really take on using ai
your ceo is often your top advocate to
help
bring the adoption of ai and ml in the
business
third is thinking about how you can test
for scale
so given there's so many different use
cases you could go after
it's a best practice to use proof of
concepts to prove the value
to your leadership team and then get
kind of resources and more attention to
move forward with more use cases going
forward
it can give executives and your
stakeholders
a firm sense of what type of value they
can expect
and how they can be interacting with
data to drive value
and then last is going mainstream so
thinking about how you can
better expose data and insights to
all of the users within your
organization
thinking about tools like looker to help
visualize
and help people understand what the data
might be telling them
this will speed your rate of change and
bring people along the journey
much faster this is kind of taking data
out of the rear view mirror
and putting it into something that
directs the future
of your organization
so now that we've talked about solutions
best practices
i'm excited to see what you can do to
drive the adoption of ai and ml
in your business we have a variety of
resources
available if you're interested in
learning more about each of these
solutions
customer reference examples to go a
little bit deeper
as well as partners that can help you on
your journey
i'm excited for what comes ahead in
retail data is at the center of all
digital transformations
and there's great things to come